[Music]
i'll give you guys a choice okay
we either do
we go back to the amber herd and johnny
depp trial oh that's the sheer
yeah did you see her doing a little did
you see her quoting the talent is it her
is it her doing coke
no it's her describing on how she got
[ __ ] by a bottle oh yeah
okay
his name is kevin nash first of all show
some respect and second of all he's a
former world champion all right
it's a pittance
what a pittance and he throws her [ __ ]
on the ground okay please go ahead
i'm on the countertop
he had me by the neck
and he felt like he was on top of me and
i'm look i'm looking at it in his eyes
i'm looking in his big brown
eyes go ahead sorry
i don't see him anymore it wasn't him
he's black
i have never been
so scared of my life
i couldn't
she's very bad actress but you're
supposed to be a good actress isn't that
like your whole thing no she was never a
good actor she always played [ __ ]
she always played really hot [ __ ]
to be fair
she was hot yeah so i mean
she did yeah she [ __ ] she badly fake
cried then she did a bump of coke then
she quoted the talented that mr ripley
this [ __ ]
he's a [ __ ] all quite a rollercoaster
ride is is the craziest one we've ever
seen that's famous i mean yeah next
she's gonna [ __ ] on the stand and you
know throw it at johnny it's gonna be
great
bro
all my years even i've never met a woman
this bad [ __ ] okay
jj
marsh give me your input on this okay is
this really her doing coke
okay
mental condition
oh
a lot of people
a lot of people have come out and
watched that clip and been like
this [ __ ] is doing coke black twitter
was posting
the same thing but with different
vernacular like yo for real does [ __ ]
just take a bump in the courtroom homie
like every person that's watched this
clip is like
you s i i think
she sprinkled a little bit onto the
[ __ ] onto the [ __ ] uh
whatever the tissue and then just kind
of was like
she definitely was not like snorting she
pushed it in and like
swift she was pulling in
it's just a replay
yeah yeah playing again plating and
putting it
see she's doing something all right
she's taking it on there
ah yeah and now she's doing the yeah the
the follow through
yeah yeah yeah i'm by vote yes
good honor though do we think that do we
think it might not just it might not be
cook it could be [ __ ] grounded pills
too adderall maybe
i'm not saying it but you know
i think it's coke though
did you see her when she was taught we
we yeah we watched it when she was
talking about like yeah like you know
they were like doing dru i don't really
do drugs except for like mushrooms like
you [ __ ] do drugs shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] we've seen the videos yeah we know
jim's
what are you waking up an unconscious
cartoon
i think it's the look on her eyes
afterwards it's like did someone catch
me
yeah what do you think it's there what
are you waking up a [ __ ] uh are you
waking up a cartoon character yeah
johnny depp you're trying to get right
it's a good point
go ahead first play play one more time
please
one more yes
because okay so the beginning part it's
down it looks like she put some like she
was right like she's putting something
on it
and
then
she thought she would smoke
i would slow-mo but twitter doesn't do
that oh we know ah how do you how do you
like it no it does it's just never never
when you want it to
just does it on your own
very good point um
frozen i do not even really what you do
every day royce by the way pull up the
me neither pull up the twitter hey
what
no it's not what you meant it's not
putting up with you
so if you look at um if you look at this
this uh [ __ ] uh
the tweet minimize you just for one
second
okay
the tweet says amber heard
okay amber heard says johnny depp's
jealousy towards james franco was a
nightmare here is uh here she is
sneaking into frank and here she is
sneaking franco to johnny's home when he
was out of town oh yeah i've seen this
that was wild oh yeah that was bro crazy
i saw this on twitter today over there
i'm like jesus man
ah she was a hoe for show huh
she is
is a whole face
you can't cure these hoes
right uh do we have anything
anything else from her
uh well again there is the beer bottle
there is her getting
supposedly cavilly searched by johnny
depp
a cavity search yeah he lost a bottle
he would cavity surger yeah let it sit
what would you do
the same thing
grandmother gave him that bottle
i've been drinking whiskey out of that
bottle since i was eight years old
[Music]
i need that bubble back
your honor that's a lie it was a
decanter
let's take that take that cocaine out of
your [ __ ] and give it to you yeah he
lost the bottom
box
well apparently i could fit a bottle so
i mean
and like when she was explaining it i
thought she was gonna go into fisting
but she brought the bottle into it and
i'm like
lady you should hold back just a little
bit you know what kind of bottle are we
talking about a bottle
i was going to say because a beer bottle
i think would still theoretically be
more forgiving than their fists right
this they should just be all luckily and
[ __ ] they showed a picture of it
that's true big shows
yeah we're some asian you know yeah
go ahead
this is serious sorry go ahead
looking at me and i was trying to get
through to him i was trying to say
to him in some way
but it was me
i was trying to get through to
johnny
i couldn't see him i couldn't see him at
all
pause
hey she's a good actress when you cry
you're supposed to have water come on in
your eyes yeah she's wrong she's used to
having somebody go cut
look we will be here all day if we have
to but we're getting this right
you know it's that's kind of hard let me
help you out pretend you ran out of
pills
maybe you shouldn't have brought pills
yeah you know what i mean
see i can give a drasty of that at least
she's learned the snake tear method
where
you know she cries now it's not just a
dry dry snitch on your mental illness to
fight 50 million dollars on the line in
a defamation case and i wanted to seem
like i was abused i would detox from
everything for days leading up to my
testosterone yeah just make sure you see
that i'm a shaky crying mess that piss
is totally clean and they're like
look what you did to this [ __ ] guy
the minute we get him talking about it
he's a blubbering mess and then as soon
as my [ __ ] testimony's over the next
day coming all sand out like
i'm fine i'm okay i'm sorry about hey i
want to just stay on the jury i'm very
sorry about yesterday
all right uh go ahead frozen i'm going
to skip a little bit
[Music]
backwards
i'm a bar meaning my chest was up
i was staring at the blue lights and
my
chest
my back was on the
donor tops
all right pause i'm sorry we could agree
that she's terrible yes that amber heard
no no but it's worse than that
yeah amber hurt is a bad actress yes but
amber heard's a bad actress
for like a regular [ __ ]
like forget that she's been in a bunch
of movies as an actor
she's not she's not even if you had a
girlfriend talking to you like this
you'd be like i've dated [ __ ] that
were better than this you're not even
good at this it's she's she i thought
johnny depp was a good actor how do you
fall for this [ __ ]
drunk how hot she was
that's all it is i mean i'm telling you
that's all it is she's hot and he's old
she's hot and she's bot and she's
[ __ ] bisexual you don't think that
means you was gonna [ __ ] her and like
two other chicks of course he was he's
johnny depp and she's telling the story
of getting a bottle shoved in her ass i
somehow don't think that was the first
time that happened no
i think this is the first time today
that's how fatty arbuckle died
[Laughter]
good
and i
thought he was punching me
i have to do more coke
amber doing coke in the courtroom is a q
drop no that's a key bump yeah
well though yeah
[ __ ]
that's a key bump